le premier meurtre a eu lieu avant ma
naissance
on organisait une commémoration annuelle
le tueur se faisait appeler l'étrangleur
que vous tuerez longer dossier du siège
il ya une manette en dessous pour moi il
n'était qu'une ombre du passé c'est quoi
ça tu as trouvé ça ou juste là
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour
oui la dépêche toi des éléments armés
allen et bon appétit
ça c'est délicieux
je peux te parler
cette photo n'était pas à moi on était
dans la voiture de mon père d'aillleurs
tu l'as vu le quai
tu fait fuir tous tes potes
savoir serrer des noeuds ça vous servira
toute votre vie en famille comment
l'extérieur
tu connais l'histoire de l'étrangleur
pourquoi tu te susic a tout d'un coup
[Musique]
je me trompe sûrement mais
chez qui tue et des soi disant pour
étudier
je vécu avec lui toute ma vie j'aurai
remarqué des indices tu sais nos pères
ne nous disent pas tout
l'étrangleur
et la torture et à leurs habits toi
c'est l'heure de resserrer nos liens
fiston
tu l'as dit à quelqu'un
papa
des check rackers
cheese des crackers